[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
chers amis tout à l'heure quand je
descendais l'aller l'une d'entre vous
m'a dit devant la ferveur de cette salle
devant la chaleur de cette salle c'est
comme ça ici à marseille
et bien c'est une joie de voir que
marseille est là ce soir merci
infiniment pour votre présence si
nombreuse et je voudrais commencer par
dire de tout coeur un immense merci à
tous ceux qui parmi vous nous font la
joie de venir de loin vous avez pris de
votre temps vous êtes venus ici ce soir
vous avez choisi de consacrer cette
soirée à cette élection européenne que
tout le monde disait pourtant joué
d'avancé bien qu'il se passe quelque
chose et votre simple présence en est un
signe visible
je ne voudrais pas à trahir une
confidence mais nous avons une petite
boucle de messages sur laquelle nous
échangeons et à l'instant bruno gilles
vient de publier un message en disant à
marseille cinq mille personnes
c'était des chiffres marseillais mais
c'est la réalité vous êtes tellement
nombreux et tout ceci nous portent bien
sûr je voudrais remercier monsieur le
maire d'être ici ce soir c'est une joie
d'être avec vous de partager ce moment
vous incarnez cette ville et je vous le
disais tout à l'heure je crois que ce
qui fait la force de notre famille
politique c'est justement cette
extraordinaire complémentarité entre des
destins liés à des territoires qu'ils
ont marqué de leur empreinte
est ce que nous apportons ce que nous
tentons d'apporter humblement à notre
modeste mesure dans ce défi européen
je n'ai jamais été ma chronique parce
que j'ai n'ai jamais cru que le nouveau
monde et est forcément meilleur que
l'ancien et je sais que ce qui fait
l'efficacité de notre action c'est
toujours la complémentarité qui peut se
tisser entre nous je voudrais remercier
infiniment bruno gilles de ces motions
encourageant martine vassal bien sûr de
sa présence de sa confiance nous ne nous
connaissons pas encore très bien mais
cette soirée et le début du lien qu'il
faudra créer pour que nous soyons
efficaces ensemble au cours des
prochaines années au service
de votre territoire dans ce travail qui
s'engagent au parlement européen pour
pouvoir creuser le sillon que d'autres
ont commencé et c'est évidemment une
joie particulière pour moi de dire un
immense merci pour sa confiance pour son
engagement pour son action à renaud
muselier
merci au no je vais pas être très long
parce qu'on est tous là pour ton
anniversaire bien sûr j'ai c'est que au
début de cette campagne
tu avais pu montrer que tu te poser des
questions je te rassure chez renault je
m'en suis posé moi aussi mais je veux
dire qu'il ya un argument que tu avais
mis en avant et que je n'ai pas compris
et c'est le moment pour moi de te
partager mon incompréhension du fond du
coeur tu avais dit ça peut pas marcher
parce que je suis marseillais et il est
versailles et et alors il faut que je te
dise renault que peut-être depuis le sud
ça paraît être tout proche mais rassure
toi
les versaillais ne sont pas des
parisiens et non nous allons pouvoir
travailler ensemble au cours des
prochaines années
et puis je voudrais remercier enfin ceux
qui sont ici ce soir vous avez vu ce
qu'ils sont de votre territoire mais ils
sont nombreux dans cette salle au fond
beaucoup d'entre vous me l'ont dit
encore tout à l'heure comme si cette
dynamique pouvait être lié à une seule
personne bien je suis désolé de vous
décevoir ce n'est pas le cas la
dynamique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui elle est d'abord le résultat
d'un travail d'équipé et laurent je
voudrais te dire un immense merci parce
que tu m'as fait cette chance de
m'investir d'abord de me témoigner de la
confiance mais de m'investir dès le
début de cette campagne
avec ce trio de tête avec agnès avec
arnaud et 2 j'ai tout appris et j'ai
tout reçu et nous vivons dans cette
dernière phase de la campagne qui
s'engage un moment assez douloureux
puisque nous sommes maintenant séparés
sur le terrain agnès et arnaud nous
faisons campagne chacun de notre côté
pour démultiplier nos forces mais je
voudrais dire puisqu'il est là ce soir
tout ce que je dois à arnaud si parfois
quand vous m'avez entendu dans les
médias à la radio à la télévision vous
avez trouvé que ce que je disais ce
n'est juste c'est parce que ça venait
pas de moi c'est parce qu'un homme
l'avait appris et je voudrais lui dire
un immense merci pour tout ce qu'il m'a
transmis depuis le début de cette
campagne
ce qui fait la force de notre famille
politique ce qui fait la force de notre
équipe c'est d'abord quel est le
résultat de cette complémentarité
magnifique et c'est cette unité de notre
famille rassemblée autour d'un projet
clair derrière toi laurent autour d'une
vision pour l'europe avec 75
propositions que nous portons que nous
martelons depuis le début de cette
campagne
c'est cette unité de notre famille
réconcilier pour parler d'une seule voix
de cette europe que nous voulons
kiffer l'élan que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et je voudrais remercier
ceux qui sont ici avec nous de ce
territoire de ce département remercier
patrick remercier sahara vous avez
entendu à l'instant ils sont la voix de
notre famille ils sont la voie de notre
équipe
ici dans ce territoire ils sont ce soir
avec kevin avec bernard avec livia avec
philippe avec laeticia avec
arnaud que je citais tout à l'heure et
avec geoffroy que vous avez vu surfer de
fait notre directeur de campagne
nous pouvons tous les applaudir parce
que tous ils font campagne et ils sont
tous responsables de cet élan tu me
connais son jeu ou alors peut-être
maintenant parlons d'europe car
effectivement c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
nous voulons parler d'europe
parce que nous sommes à un carrefour de
notre histoire est un carrefour de
l'histoire de notre europe
nous sommes venus ici avec la joie de
nous retrouver
mais nous avons tous au fond de nous
mêmes aussi dans le coeur une inquiétude
est comme une angoisse et cette question
qui nous hante
est ce que cette europe dont nous
héritons va durer encore longtemps
va-t-elle encore écrire l'histoire bien
souvent nous avons l'impression
aujourd'hui d'être en train de subir une
histoire qui se fait sans nous d'être
devenus les spectateurs des événements
plutôt que ceux qui les font et nous
avons le sentiment de nous trouver peu à
peu dépossédé de notre capacité d'agir
si tant de français se tiennent à
distance de la vie politique citant deux
français se tiennent à distance de cette
élection qui s'approche
c'est peut-être parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que rien ne peut en sortir
parce que quoi qu'ils votent à la fin
rien ne pourra jamais changer
et bien c'est à cela qu'il faut mettre
un terme
c'est à ce sentiment d'impuissance
collective c'est à ce désarroi qu'il
faut apporter une réponse est ma
conviction profonde c'est que ce
désarroi nous n'y répondront pas à
simplement en insultant depuis le début
de cette campagne tous les jours sur le
terrain
nous entendons la voix de ceux qui nous
disent qu'ils ont le sentiment que
l'europe leur a manqué qu ils ont le
sentiment que l'europe ne parvient pas à
faire face aux grands défis de notre
temps qu'ils ont le sentiment même
parfois n'ayant pas peur des mots que
l'europe les a trahis au lieu de les
renforcer et bien à tous ces gens là à
ces agriculteurs qui se démène auxquels
on impose des règles toujours plus
complexe et qu on contourne ensuite en
faisant venir sur notre propre marché
des produits qui ne respectent pas les
normes qu'on leur avait imposé à ces
entrepreneurs qui ont le sentiment d'une
paralysie administrative qui
tu le disais cher hervé vient bien sûr
souvent d'abord de nos propres pesanteur
à tous ceux qui travaillent et qui ne
parviennent pas à s'en sortir et qu'ils
ont l'impression que nous perdons que
nous reculons dans la mondialisation au
lieu de parvenir à conquérir de nouveaux
à tout cela nous devons apporter des
réponses
il ne suffira pas de traiter de
populiste tous ceux qui s'inquiètent
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir faire en sorte
que leurs inquiétudes disparaissent il
faut d'abord leur apporter des réponses
il ya ceux qui prospère sur les peurs et
nous leur laissons ce marketing de la
peur il ya ceux qui préfèrent le déni de
réalité et nous leur laissons ce déni de
réalité
il ya ceux qui disent dans cette
campagne c'était le cas de celui qui est
tête de liste du rassemblement national
que le but pour lui dans cette élection
c'est de faire pleurer christophe
castaner et il ya ceux qui disent dans
cette campagne c'était le premier
discours de même l'oiseau lors de son
lancement de campagne que le but de leur
campagne c'est de battre le
rassemblement national
ils veulent tous se battre entre eux eh
bien nous notre seul but dans cette
campagne c'est de résoudre les problèmes
des français et c'est de refaire une
europe qui soit efficace pour répondre
aux problèmes des français
karoui karoui nous croyons à l'europe
oui nous croyons que l'europe est plus
nécessaire que jamais les chars laurent
tu le sais ce projet que tu portes
depuis si longtemps
c'est le projet d'une europe qui puisse
se refonder pour pouvoir être de nouveau
efficace est de nouveau conquérante
oui nous croyons que l'europe est plus
nécessaire que jamais mais nous croyons
que pour que l'europe puisse faire la
preuve de son efficacité il faut
refonder en profondeur la manière dont
elle se construit et c'est le cas pour
faire face par exemple à ce grand défi
que le défi industriel et commercial qui
est devant nous aujourd'hui nous avons
le sentiment que l'avenir du monde
s'écrit en chine ou aux états unis
parce que nous avons le sentiment que
l'europe est le dernier endroit qu'ils
cèdent encore à la naïveté dans les
années 1990 un philosophe américain par
des modes de revenir à mon tropisme
professionnel dans les années 90 est un
philosophe américain qui s'appelait
francis fukuyama a écrit un livre qui
s'appelait la fin de l'histoire
et dans ce livre il expliquait que le
mur de berlin s'était effondré et que
personne ne s'était enfui à l'est
et que par conséquent le parti
socialiste a mis du temps à s'en rendre
compte mais c'était le cas que par
conséquent l'histoire avait tranché que
l'histoire avait tranché en faveur de la
démocratie libérale et que petit à petit
on allait voir ce modèle s'étendre
universellement à la surface de la
planète que toutes les barrières allait
se défaire que toutes les frontières
allait s'effacer que les identités alès
diluée et qu'on allait passer petit à
petit de la figure du citoyen préoccuper
de l'avenir politique de son pays à la
figure du consommateur auquel une
concurrence libre et non faussée étendu
à la surface de la planète apporterait
le meilleur produit au moindre coût est
bien le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que ça ne s'est pas passé comme ça et
que l'histoire ne s'est pas terminée et
que nous sommes peut-être les derniers
en europe à croire encore à cette fin de
l'histoire
arnaud me le confiait il y a
effectivement parmi ces parlementaires
européens notamment dans le groupe des
libéraux des gens qui pensent qu'il faut
le libre échange à tout va qu'il faut
s'ouvrir et montrer l'exemple de
l'ouverture et que tout le monde va nous
imiter mais la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes arrivés aujourd'hui est elle
normale
est il normal que par exemple nos
marchés publics qui représentent 20% de
la valeur produite en europe que nos
marchés publics soit ouvert à 95% aux
acteurs internationaux alors que ces
mêmes acteurs eux nous ferme les leurs
les marchés publics américains ne sont
couverts qu'à 30%
les marchés publics russes à 0% les
marchés publics chinois à 0%
est il normal qu'une entreprise chinoise
puisse venir prendre les marchés publics
en france alors que jamais une
entreprise française
même la plus compétente même la mieux
qualifiée
jamais une entreprise française ne
pourra prendre un marché public en chine
est ce normal notre famille politique
croire au libre échange nous croyons à
la liberté
et dans cette ville de marseille qui a
si souvent marqué l'histoire du monde
par cette capacité de commerce et
d'échangés nous croyons bien sûr à la
fécondité de ce doux commerce dont
parlait montesquieu qui rapproche les
hommes entre eux mais nous croyons que
les vertus de la compétition dont un
sens quand les règles sont les mêmes
pour tous et ce qui vaut au stade
vélodrome vont aussi bien sûr dans la
compétition économique mondiale
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous car sinon évidemment c'est le
principe même de cette liberté qui est
détruit de l'intérieur c'est le principe
même de cette europe qui se trouve
disqualifiée
nous ne croyons pas à une europe
forteresse entre laquelle il faudrait se
réfugier entre quatre murs pour mourir à
petit feu
nous n'avons pas renoncé à être
compétitif ne nous sommes pas résignés à
rester en marge de la compétition
mondiale
mais encore faut-il pour jouer ce jeu
que les règles soient les mêmes pour
tous et il faut maintenant que nous
fassions de ce marché unique que
l'europe a su construire un outil
politique est un levier pour peser dans
la mondialisation
peut-être seuls nous ne pourrions pas
c'est ce que la grande-bretagne découvre
aujourd'hui à l'occasion du bric site
parce qu'on peut contourner un marché de
quelques dizaines de millions
d'habitants
mais personne ne peut contourner un
marché de 500 millions d'habitants
personne ne peut faire sans l'europe
même la chine même les états unis et il
est temps de faire de ce marché unique
une force dans la mondialisation et de
dire à nos partenaires si vous voulez
echanger il faut respecter nos règles et
alors rien ne nous arrêtera
car nous croyons à la force de nos
entreprises à l'excellence de nos savoir
faire
nous croyons à l'engagement de tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui contre vents et marées
travail en france et font la richesse de
ce pays malgré toutes les difficultés
malgré le découragement que peut leur
inspirer c'est vrai un état qui passe
son temps à multiplier les règles et les
normes au lieu de pouvoir les soutenir
malgré tout cela nous avons encore la
capacité nous en sommes convaincus de
rayonner longtemps dans le monde et dans
l'histoire
encore faut-il que nous puissions faire
de cette europe que nous avons
construite un outil politique et elle
peut l'être et elle doit l'être et elle
le sera parce que c'est ce que nous
allons défendre au cours des prochaines
années
refonder l'europe pour pouvoir rétablir
la france voilà le coeur de notre
engagement
le socle de notre projet
sortir de la naïveté pour apporter un
nouvel équilibre monde de demain c'est
aussi bien sûr ce qui est attendu de
tous sur cette question fondamentale
qu'est la question migratoire
je suis parfois frappé de voir à quel
point nous sommes encore sur ce sujet
dans le déni de réalité
je suis frappé d'entendre des
contradicteurs me dire pourquoi parler
d'immigration tout cela est déjà finie
la crise migratoire c'est et en 2015 et
maintenant c'est terminé
eh bien nous le savons tous chers amis
et disons le sans détourner le regard
la crise migratoire n'a pas encore
commencé parce que le défi que
représente la démographie du continent
africain est largement devant nous et si
nous ne savons pas maîtriser nos
frontières si nous ne savons pas
maîtriser les flux migratoires
alors nous allons continuer de produire
du malheur à grande échelle malheur bien
sûr
mahler bien sûr malheur pour nos
sociétés qui sont déjà profondément
fracturé par le communautarisme qui les
touche et qui les gangrènes du fait
d'une immigration que nous n'avons pas
su maîtriser et que par conséquent nous
n'avons pas su intégrer malheurs du fait
de ces logique communautariste qui
construit cette france archipel dont
parle jérôme fourquet qui nous éloigne
les uns des autres
malheur parce que l'impuissance
d'aujourd'hui est le ferment des
tensions et des divisions de demain mais
malheur aussi évidemment pour tous ces
jeunes venus d'afrique auquel des
passeurs sans scrupules dans le miroir
aux alouettes d'un eldorado qu'ils ne
trouveront pas en arrivant en europe et
tous ces jeunes auxquels nous disons aux
quels nous laissons dire par notre
impuissance d'aujourd'hui qu'il pourrait
avoir un avenir chez nous au lieu de
dessiner leur avenir chez eux pour
développer leur pays tous tous ces
jeunes là seront directement les
victimes de ce que certains appellent
générosité mais qui n'est que de
l'inconséquence et qui n'est encore une
fois que le signe de notre impuissance
et nous le savons bien sûr vous le savez
mieux que personne ici à marseille au
bord de cette mer méditerranée qui a été
si douloureusement endeuillé par ces
naufragés pors et par ses morts pourquoi
ces morts sinon parce que les passeurs
prospère sur un seul et unique levier
c'est que si on arrive à mettre le pied
sur le sol européen même de manière
illégale
on a toutes les chances de pouvoir y
rester
le jour où cette équation sera défaite
le jour où il sera certain qu'on ne peut
rester en europe que si on a eu le droit
d'y rentrer de manière légale ce jour là
il n'y aura plus un seul mort en mer
méditerranée et pour cela et pour cela
il faut mettre en oeuvre ce que nous
défendons depuis le début de cette
campagne mettre en oeuvre une double
frontières d'abord une frontière
européenne qui soit vraiment défendu
mettre en oeuvre une stratégie
européenne pour défendre les frontières
extérieures de l'europe car nous ne
croyons pas un seul instant que chacun
de nos pays sera plus fort si les seuls
face à l'ampleur de ce défi qui peut
penser sérieusement que la grèce seule
permettra de défendre ses îles et son
territoire qui ne voit que lorsque
l'italie ferme ses frontières s'est
instantanément par l'espagne que les
flux migratoires se déplacer que c'est
par les pyrénées qu'il rentre
aujourd'hui en france il faut donc
mettre en oeuvre une vraie stratégie
commune pour défendre les frontières
extérieures de l'europe et faire en
sorte que effectivement les demandes
d'asile et les demandes de titres de
séjour ne soient effectués qu'en dehors
des frontières extérieures de l'europe
quand votre pays est en guerre on
connaît la difficulté que vous quittez
votre pays qui est dans une situation de
crise profonde vous n'arrivez jamais
directement à paris vous n'arrivez
jamais directement à marseille
votre route vous conduit par d'autres
pays par d'autres états qui sont
dans une situation sûr et stable et dans
lesquels vous devez pouvoir demander
l'asile en france ou en europe et alors
si vous êtes éligible à l'asile car nous
croyons au droit d'asile à ce gain
magnifique à cet apport extraordinaire
de la civilisation européenne
si vous êtes éligible à l'asile alors
vous serez admis en europe
et si vous n'y êtes pas éligible il faut
que vous puissiez savoir déjà que si
vous mettez le pied sur le sol européen
vous n'avez aucune chance d'y rester il
faut que celui qui entrent illégalement
sur le sol européen ne puisse pas
demandé à rester sur le sol européen
car sinon encore une fois nous laissons
prospérer ce business des passeurs cette
traite d'êtres humains qui fait
aujourd'hui notre honte collective
et puis il faut que cette stratégie
européenne pour défendre nos frontières
soient mises au service d'une véritable
maîtrise par chacun de nos états de leur
politique migratoire
contrairement au rassemblement national
même croyons pas un seul instant que
nous serons plus forts seuls et le
rassemblement national tu le rappeler
cher renault a effectivement voté au
cours des dernières années
systématiquement pour montrer qu'il ne
croyait pas à l'europe et que par
idéologie il était prêt à sacrifier sur
l'autel de cette idéologie les intérêts
les plus vitaux de chacune de nos
nations
mais nous ne croyons pas non plus une
seule seconde contrairement à monsieur
macron que l'europe doivent être le nom
de notre dépossession politique de la
dépossession de nos souverainetés de
celle de chacun de nos pays nous ne
croyons pas un seul instant que l'europe
puisse imposer des quotas de migrants
aux états qui la composent
sans se discréditer d'une manière
définitive nous pensons que l'europe
doit être ce par quoi nos pays sont
renforcés et n'ont pas affaibli
nous pensons que l'europe doit être ce
par quoi chaque pays peut gérer
effectivement selon ses capacités
d'accueil et d'intégration gérer
démocratiquement sa politique migratoire
et nous ne croyons pas à cette politique
de quotas d'immigration dont le
président de la république parlait il ya
encore peu de temps qui consiste
seulement à gérer notre impuissance au
lieu d'y mettre vraiment faim voilà ce
que nous défendons dans cette campagne
européenne
voilà ce que nous sommes les seuls à
défendre dans cette campagne européenne
cette double frontières dont nous avons
besoin pour faire face à ce défi immense
qui est devant nous c'est aussi la
condition pour que nous puissions
reconstruire l'avenir de nos sociétés
parce que l'avenir de nos sociétés se
trouve dans le fait de pouvoir former de
nouveau une communauté politique
l'avenir de notre pays il se joue dans
la question de savoir si nous serons
redevenir une communauté nationale
ce qui est en train de se jouer sous nos
yeux c'est la fracturation de cette
société fracturation avec laquelle le
président de la république a si
dangereusement jouer
emmanuel macron quand il est venu à
marseille pendant sa campagne
présidentielle avait fait un grand
discours et ce discours je crois a été
ou aurait dû être un grand moment de
vérité
s'adressant à la salle qui était devant
lui à marseille dans cette ville qui est
si souvent prises comme étant l'exemple
même de cette communautarisation à tort
ou à raison de la société d'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron avait dit je vois des
comoriens
je vois des algériens je vois des
marocains je vois des afghans je vois et
il avait terminé en disant au delà de
tout cela je vois des français et bien
voilà exactement ce qui menace notre
société emmanuel macron aurait dû ne
voir que des français
mais je ne veux pas je ne veux pas le
lui reprocher car je crois qu'en cela il
n'était pas l'auteur de ce
communautarisme qui touche notre société
il en était simplement l'un des
symptômes il y a trop longtemps
maintenant que nous avons laissé
prospérer l'idée qu'il n'ya pas de
culture française que nous n'avons rien
en commun que nous sommes des
communautés juxtaposer les unes aux
autres
des individus émancipée qui
s'additionnent par le jeu du contrat ou
des groupes humains qui se rencontrent
par l'effet de cette espèce de
multiculturalisme qui n'est rien d'autre
que la préparation d'une société où les
conflits se multiplient à l'infini
nous avons à redécouvrir la force de ce
lien qui nous unit et c'est aussi
évidemment un grand sujet européen car
dans ce rendez vous de l'élection
européenne
il y à hofu une question fondamentale et
je crois que là aussi nous sommes un peu
je le regrette
les seuls à la portée aujourd'hui
l'europe
c'est un très beau projet mais l'europe
ça n'est pas d'abord un projet et si ce
projet est possible c'est d'abord parce
que l'europe est lié par une unité
profonde unité intérieure
une unité est essentielle l'europe c'est
l'histoire de cette paix enfin obtenu
par nos aînés après les guerres qu'ils
ont traversés mais si cette paix a été
possible
c'est d'abord parce que nos nations
étaient déjà eu ni les unes aux autres
par un lien auquel elle avait si souvent
manqué et ce lien n'est pas éphémère
il vient du fond des âges ce lien à
plusieurs millénaires d'histoire
l'europe est d'abord une civilisation
j'étais il ya quelques jours à athènes
je me suis fait gronder par laurent
parce qu'ils trouvent que j'en fais trop
et c'est vrai que dans cette campagne
le rythme est bien intense nous allons
partout en france au contact des
français mais je tenais profondément et
c'était peut-être quelque chose d'un peu
irrationnel mais tellement fondamentale
pour moi à ce que cette campagne passe
par la grèce parce que la grèce c'est le
lieu de toutes les fragilités de
l'europe d'aujourd'hui la grèce c'est le
lieu qui vit le plus durement la crise
économique qui a touché ce pays du fait
des déséquilibres de la zone euro du
fait de cette impuissance à faire face à
la mondialisation que nous connaissons
la grèce est effectivement en première
ligne face à la crise migratoire et
c'est elle qui apportait fortement le
poids de cette crise que laurent tu as
été voir dans les îles grecques que tu
as visité mais la grèce si elle est le
lieu de la plus grande fragilité de
l'europe d'aujourd'hui est aussi le lieu
où l'europe montre ce qu'elle est et ce
qu'elle a de plus fort et la grèce
athènes c'est bien sûr le lieu de notre
civilisation commune
l'europe c'est d'abord ce petit miracle
gré c'est d'abord ce miracle grec si
fragile qui a fondé marseille 600 ans
avant jésus-christ auquel nous devons
temps c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'europe doit tant à marseille parce que
c'est par marseille que l'esprit grec à
traverser toute l'europe
c'est par marseille que ce petit miracle
de la liberté n'est sur l'agora a
commencé à se diffuser partout sur le
sol européen
cette aspiration à la raison ce désir de
démocratie la volonté de faire de nos
désaccords l'occasion d'un dialogue
plutôt que d'un combat la volonté
d'écrire ensemble notre histoire plutôt
que de la subir tout cela est née en
grèce et c'est aussi à athènes que l'
empire romain est venu à la source de
cet esprit grec qu'il a profondément
transformé
on est parfois vaincu par sa conquête et
quand rome a conquis athènes c'est rome
qui en a été retourné sur la colline du
parthénon tools empire romain a trouvé
ce renouvellement qui a fait de l'europe
ce qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui et
c'est sur cette même colline de la pnyx
qu'un juif qui était le premier des
chrétiens et qui s'appelait saint paul
est venue enseigner ce qu'est t
la révélation chrétienne c'est dans
l'agora c'est sur l'acropole qu'on
retrouve ces sur l'acropole qu'on
retrouve ces trois traditions qui ont
fait l'europe la tradition grecque la
tradition romaine
et pourquoi ne pas le dire pourquoi
avoir tellement tardé à la dira la
nommer parmi nos racines la tradition
chrétienne
tout cela a fait l'europe
et le dire et le dire ce n'est pas
défendre une europe communautariste vous
m'avez bien compris cette histoire
n'appartient pas à ceux qui aujourd'hui
se disent croyants nous l'avons tous
vécu d'ailleurs nous l'avons tous
ressenti lorsque nous avons dans ce
moment éprouvant et pourtant
singulièrement émouvant lorsque nous
avons tous ensemble éprouvé la même
émotion lorsque nous avons vu brûler
notre dame de paris dans les flammes de
cette cathédrale
nous avons tous sentis en regardant nos
écrans de télévision que nous avions le
coeur retourné que nous avions quelque
chose en nous qu'ils étaient directement
touché jusque dans nos tripes presque et
nous avons tous senti que c'était au
fond de nous mêmes une part de
nous-mêmes qui brûlait on n'a pas besoin
d'être croyant on n'a pas besoin d'être
chrétien pour savoir que ce lien nous
attache et qu'il fait notre vie
d'aujourd'hui
j'ai eu l'occasion j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger
je n'ai déjà raconté mais c'est un
moment qui m'a profondément marqué dans
cette campagne j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger
il ya quelques jours de cela avec le
général qui commandait qui commande et
qui commandait ce soir là les sapeurs
pompiers de paris avec lequel les marins
pompiers de marseille ont des liens si
étroits bien sûr et nous parlions
ensemble au moment où je venais lui dire
notre reconnaissance à tous pour l'
extraordinaire qui avait fait ses hommes
ce soir pour sauver cette cathédrale
nous échangions ensemble sur cette chose
si étonnante si mystérieuse au fond
lorsque les lorsque le le toit de cette
cathédrale brûlés alors que les deux
tours de notre-dame était sur le point
d'être atteinte
ces hommes sont montés dans les tours
pour aller éteindre le feu il n'y avait
pourtant pas une seule vie humaine a
sauvé ses hommes sont montés dans des
tours qui pouvait à tout instant
s'écrouler et ils ont risqué leur vie et
ils ont risqué leur vie n'ont pas pour
sauver d'autres vies
mais pour sauver une cathédrale ils ont
risqué leur vie et aucun d'entre eux
deux aucun d'entre eux me disais ce
général aucun d'entre eux n'a reculé
ils ont risqué leur vie pour aller
sauver des pierres parce que ces pierres
sont vivantes
parce que ces pierres sont notre vie
parce qu'elles sont la vie d'une société
qui sait se reconnaître en héritage
commun et nous devons leur dire un
immense merci d'avoir sauvé ce lieu qui
peut être pour l'avenir le lieu d'un
espoir retrouvé
il n'y a là rien d'anecdotique
il y à là quelque chose d'essentiel
qu'est ce qui fait notre lien qu'est ce
qui fait notre unité
qu'est-ce-qui doux que nous soyons doux
que nous venions peut aujourd'hui encore
nous réunir et nous attachés les uns aux
autres je le dis comment ces unions
nous avons à combattre évidemment tout
ce qui menace l'équilibré même de notre
société est aujourd'hui le principal de
ces défis le premier de nos ennemis
c'est cet islam radical qui éloigne tant
de jeunes du pays dans lequel ils vivent
et où ils devraient se reconnaître
face à cet islam radical face au
terrorisme islamiste qui a tué et qui a
fait tant de morts il faut évidemment
cher arnaud des réponses policières il
faut évidemment des réponses judiciaires
et elles sont au coeur du projet que
nous portons
mais je le dis aussi face à ce défi de
l'islam radical
nous ne gagnerons pas la bataille si
nous ne savons pas d'abord re dire qui
nous sommes
si nous ne savons pas d'abord
transmettre à tous les jeunes qui
grandissent en france un héritage dans
lequel ils puissent se retrouver un élan
a continué une culture à partager
l'islam radical ne prospère que sur le
vide que nous avons laissé derrière nous
en nous interdisant de partager une
culture commune en s'adressant à chacun
à partir de sa nationalité d'origine
plutôt qu'en le regardant chacun comme
le français qui les français de coeur ou
d'histoire français quoi qu'il arrive en
refusant de transmettre à tous ces
jeunes cet héritage dont parce qu'ils
sont français ils sont tous les légitime
héritier nous avons aujourd'hui à
vaincre cette bataille à vaincre dans
cette bataille le plus dangereux des
ennemis et pour pouvoir l'emporter il
faut d'abord pouvoir savoir pourquoi
nous combattons pourquoi nous sommes
engagés pour quel héritage magnifique
nous sommes aujourd'hui impliquée pour
pouvoir tenter de faire en sorte que
notre pays ne sortent pas de l'histoire
que notre continent retrouve ce qu'il
est pour pouvoir retrouver confiance
dans la civilisation qui peut encore
continuer d'écrire pour le meilleur
l'histoire du monde de demain il faut
savoir redire qui nous sommes et l'un
des enjeux fondamentaux que nous portons
dans cette campagne européenne
c'est l'enjeu d'une europe qui sache de
nouveau se finir en mettant fin à cette
folie des élargissements qu'ils
n'étaient que l'autre nom de notre
incapacité à nous définir tout
simplement en mettant fin aussi bien sûr
à ce déni de réalité dans lequel nous
avons si longtemps sombré
lorsque nous avons refusé par exemple de
dire dans nos traités fondateurs quelles
étaient nos racines il faut savoir
redire qui nous sommes et nommer ses
racines grecques ses racines latines ses
racines jude
chrétienne cet héritage des lumières
cette vie de la modernité critiques qui
nous anime aujourd'hui et qui fait de
nous ce que nous sommes
il faut savoir redire qui nous sommes
pour pouvoir rpt tisser ce lien qui fera
l'avenir de notre société ça n'a rien
d'anecdotique
le président de la république dans un
grand discours qu'il a prononcé au
bernardin en parlant des racines
chrétiennes de l'europe disait ce débat
sur les racines de l'europe ce débat ne
m'intéresse pas moi ce qui m'intéresse
disait-il
ce ne sont pas les racines c'est la sève
toujours la même idée que c'est le
nouveau monde contre l'ancien que pour
se projeter dans l'avenir il faudrait se
détourner du passé eh bien nous pouvons
dire à monsieur macron que toute
personne qui a planté un jour un arbre
dans sa vie c'est que vous avez peu de
chances d'avoir de la scène
si vous n'avez pas des racines
alors oui c'est vrai
oui c'est vrai nous sommes face c'est
vrai nous sommes face à ce déni de
réalité c'est vrai que nous avons à
faire face à cette inconséquence qui se
prolonge une secrétaire d'état a dit
l'autre jour à la radio que quand elle
m'entendais elle avait l'impression que
je parlais d'une europe passéiste qui
n'a jamais existé
eh bien j'avais envie de lui offrir un
aller-retour pour athènes ou de lui
offrir un aller-retour pour marseille
dont chateaubriand disait qu'elle était
la nouvelle athènes et puisque c'est en
grèce qui est né cet esprit et puisque
c'est à marseille qu'il s'est diffusée
alors il faut que ce soit à marseille
que commence la refondation de cette
europe dont nous avons besoin pour
pouvoir rétablir la france et cela mes
chers amis
cela dépend seulement de vous vous êtes
l'avenir de ce débat vous est la
condition du succès que nous devons que
nous devons non pas seulement cher
laurent à notre famille politique mais
que nous devons à notre pays car aucun
espoir ne se trouve dans le faux débat
qu'on voulait nous imposer
entre populiste et progressistes nous
sommes en train de déjouer ce faux débat
nous sommes en train de déjouer tous les
pronostics et nous le faisons
non pas d'abord pour le succès d'un
parti ou d'une étiquette
nous le faisons ensemble cher hervé et
merci de ta confiance merci de cette
unité qui nous permet d'être fort parce
que nous faisons ce travail de terrain
tous les jours partout pour convaincre
pour pouvoir offrir aux français
l'alternative dont ils ont vraiment
besoin
le choix de l'europe qu'ils veulent et
non pas de celle qu'on voudrait leur
imposer le choix de l'europe qui a un
avenir et non pas de celle qui ne peut
qu'échouer nous avons besoin de ce
succès dans quelques semaines
dans quelques jours nous avons besoin de
ce succès pour offrir à la france
le choix de l'europe qu'elle attend pour
pouvoir se reconstruire
refonder l'europe pour rétablir la
france voilà le défi qui dépend de vous
nous allons tout donner avec tous nos
colistiers pendant les semaines qui
viennent nous allons tout donner partout
en france
mais nous avons besoin de vous besoin de
votre voix besoin de votre force de
conviction besoin de votre confiance
pour convaincre autour de vous et dans
quelques semaines j'en suis sûr
nous aurons ensemble cette belle
victoire ce sera votre victoire celle de
notre pays
vive
l'europe et vive la france et vive
marseille merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]